Hey Youtubers it's Charlie is going to be
my Star Wars trailer breakdown everybody let's
freak out this is like the last big final
trailer will get a lot more footage but this
is one of the last big huge trailers high-fives
anyone was able to buy a ticket on fandango
before it crashed like a star destroyer I
just I barely made it in under the wire you
should be able to buy tickets pretty soon
the vision they should fix the issue is that
everybody's earned online ticketing don't
don't worry everyone will get to see it.
And has up I'm actually I'm doing a special
giveaway just because this is so freaking
awesome, to give away to free IMAX movie passes
Lessig up $40 value all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video want more details at the end
of this on of the big time I will totally
not judge you if you started crying like whenever
the Star Wars music you start applying but
this is all about the force awakening it's
calling to you just let it in so it sounds
like we actually heard Lupita's character
I did next to see her but it opens on Rey's
character I know a lot of you sounded disappointed
that Rey wasn't holding a light saber in and
the poster but I do think that she's force
sensitive is a reason she's holding her staff
parallel to Kylo Ren here but I think in these
opening scenes with heard the voices were
hearing our Lupita's character Moss Cannata
talking to Rey and a lot of people are thinking
that Lupita's character might be the one to
give the protagonist Anakin Skywalker's light
saber that we've seen in previous trailers
but he is really interesting them them putting
her at the beginning of this trailer in what
she's doing here tells you about what's going
on she's investigating the star destroyer
wreckage from the battle of Jakku so it's
almost like she's rediscovering the past and
that's another big theme in the trailer all
the stories you've heard their true consoles
just think the Jedi the dark side the Empire
all those things that happen 30 years ago
they are totally true it does make you wonder
what the Imperial propaganda machine is turned
into is just really icing on the cake the
fact that she says I'm no one it just makes
you think of arias Stark in game of thrones
she is kind like the arias Stark of this movie
video looks like he starts out with the first-order
like he has a crisis of conscience he just
doesn't know what he supposed to be doing
with his life I don't know what my purposes
that's a big theme of this movie to these
new characters recognizing their purpose so
he crashes on Jakku and there's a disturbance
in the force we actually got we heard that
in the last trailer to talking to Kylo Ren's
character have you felt it this is awesome
seeing this close-up of his mask if you haven't
bought one for hollowing now's the time to
do it you can clearly see that he has gone
and scavenge the remains of Darth Vader's
armor sweeties talking to the helmet like
he feels like Darth Vader was doing something
really awesome and he wants to continue the
mission here's Poe Damron who it looks like
they captured and are interrogating is the
star destroyer wreckage again maybe after
they rescue the new characters that just looks
so much more awesome inside the morning falcon
of the battle little bit of CG most of this
is all practical though on everybody like
really appreciate is that they built a real
set on solo speechifying the past bunch of
chewy Kylo Ren with a bunch of first-order
troopers I don't think that these are the
nights of rent that's the organization that
he got his name from like he took that name
I don't know if that'll still be a thing when
the movie picks up this looks like it's after
Finn his join the resistance account remind
you of a new hope when Han Solo and Luke Skywalker
are saying their last goodbyes before they
go to a soul the death Star like good like
kid this is on solo looking like he might
be taking them to some sort of Jedi Temple
maybe he's taking them to Luke Skywalker that
I should be really awesome I'm not expecting
to see him in any of these clips supposedly
he's just going to be a bigger character in
episode a penny is an episode seven Captain
Phasma looking fabulous JJ Abrams actually
said that she is like his favorite new characters
I'm interested to see how many people love
Captain thousand she's probably going to become
like the Boba Fett person of the movie is
it that one quirky character that everyone
wants to cosplay as this is like someone really
important as diets everyone theory craft I
think it's going to be a main character but
it might be a new main character it might
not be one of the original ones she gets real
this ice planet is supposed to be where the
star killer bases and it might even be inside
the planet's core like so big that the planet
itself hides it the poster makes it look like
it's another death Star like it it's is like
an external thing that floats around but it
might be inside the planet to we we don't
we don't know yet more awesome battles this
will all be playable in video games so if
you guys want to play these don't worry you
will get the chance Princess Leia for the
first time on the resistance base and light
saber battle she gets real so I will go ahead
and say that I do not think that Darth Vader
is gonna be a big thing in this movie a lot
people were wondering they were there theories
that he might be resurrected he might appear
in some way if he appears it would be in a
flashback I'm not expecting flashbacks Kylo
Ren's character just wants to pick up where
Darth Vader left off even though Luke Skywalker
was able to redeem Vader invader, changed
his plans in the fourth quarter deep in the
fourth quarter but it is freaking awesome
footage everybody was freak out and rewatch
this like 10 more times but I do tomorrow
is post a Q&A for this were all announced
the giveaway winner and congratulations to
my reverse flash ring giveaway winner Jon
Quinn you and a reverse flash ring be sure
to private message me on the back end of my
channel so i can get your contact info.
So everybody rewatch the trailer couple more
times I put a link in the description and
I'll see you tomorrow for the Q&A video so
while you wait for everything to post you
can click here for all my Star Wars footage
and you can click here to catch up with Captain
America Civil War trailer for that coming
really soon to thank you so much watching
everybody let's high five and I'll see you
guys tomorrow!